Okay.
So a quick review of what we covered
on Thursday in the first of these two
lectures in which I'm going to be talking
about the war and hopefully as you
hopefully remember,
we began by talking about the British
and the logic of their actions during the
war.
And I talked for a little while
about a number of their logistical
disadvantages,
like um,
problems getting supplies and then
dragging them all over the American
countryside. Like the large expanse
of land that the British confronted.
That was one big battlefield in a sense.
The ways in which some kind of
traditional battle strategies,
war strategies didn't necessarily
work so well in this campaign.
And along the same lines that they were
different kinds of challenges that the
British faced in fighting
against a citizen army. Um,
I talked about how Britain couldn't
turn its back on the rest of the world,
particularly France.
They had to keep an eye on what France
was doing in France is you're going to
see in today's lecture is
going to play a large role.
And then finally I talked about the
simple fact that for the British to when
they needed to stamp out a widespread
rebellion over large expansive land,
while the Americans didn't necessarily
have to defeat the British to emerge
victorious,
they just had to keep fighting long
enough to exhaust British supplies and
funding and energies.
And I also mentioned, um,
a few mistaken assumptions
on the part of the British,
like the way that they consistently
underestimated the Americans.
And then along similar lines,
the ways in which they
consistently overestimated
the amount of loyalist support
that they were expecting
to find in the colonies.
And I spent time in Thursday's class
going into those kinds of details before
talking about phases of war and strategies
and things like that because they
help us to understand the logic of
British military strategies throughout the
war. I think it's really easy to
look back on any historical event,
but I think it's particularly true for
the American revolution that leads to the
American founding.
It's easy to look back and blame
the loser for making dumb mistakes,
but they were really logical reasons
for what the British did during this
campaign.
And that's part of what I'm trying to
bring out in last week's lecture and in
today's lecture that there were logical,
logistical reasons why
they did what they did.
There are equally logical reasons as to
why the war ultimately had the outcome
that it did.
Um,
but all of those things that I talked
about in the last lecture at the start
show how the British were acting under
pretty challenging circumstances and they
were guiding their decisions and doing
whatever they decided to do based on
whatever information and insight
and tradition they had at hand.
So their actions have a logic.
And I,
I bring that up at the start
of this lecture because
it's part of what I've been
doing overall in this class
over the course of the semester.
And that is throughout whatever
I've been lecturing about. Um,
I've tried to explain the logic and
reasoning behind people's choices and
decisions to give you a view of unfolding
events from the viewpoints of people
who were there. Now, of course,
it's just inherently interesting to look
at historical events from the viewpoint
of people who are there.
So that's part of the reason why I do
this because it's interesting and it's fun
and I find it fascinating,
but more important,
I actually take this approach because
I want to emphasize the idea that the
revolution wasn't inevitable.
It wasn't an inevitable event,
it wasn't a good revolt
against bad people.
It was actually a product
of individual choices,
individual actions on all sides.
And that's ultimately what
history is all about, right?
It's about people making
choices and then taking action.
And particularly in the case of
the American founding period,
I think it's an important
thing to remember because
it's easy to forget that the
revolution and its aftermath warrant
inevitable or inherently right?
And it has to do with
our nation's founding.
So it's natural to sort
of assume those things.
But neither one of those things helps us
to really understand what was unfolding
as the revolution unfolded.
So basically in all of my classes,
I always try to counter this sort of
seeming inevitability of things in the
founding period by really
trying to recreate the logic
of decisions at that time
in that moment.
So that's part of why I've been focusing
in that way throughout the semester.
But okay, back to the decisions of the
revolution. Um, and Thursday's lecture,
the bulk of my lecture on Thursday was
spent discussing three of the four faces
of the revolution. Um, and again,
hopefully you remember I defined these
phases based on shifts in British
strategy at various points.
So the British would shift their strategy,
the Americans would respond,
and then that phase would continue
until there'd be a new shift in a new
response. Um, just to
review very briefly here,
the first phase lasted until roughly July
of 1776 and was largely guided on the
part of the British by the assumption
that just a little coercion and maybe a
little sign of reconciliation would be
all of the Americans needed to sort of
push them into backing away and
would bring matters to a close.
That phase lasted through July,
1776 and at that point the British
stepped up their strategy by deciding to
seize New York,
seemingly one of the major cities
in the colonies. And again,
by sort of traditional war standards,
you get a major city,
you turn the tide of war.
Plus the British were hoping that if
they could sort of separate new England
from the rest of the colonies,
they might isolate the troublemakers
up in New England. And again,
maybe that would draw things to a
close. Um, in part at that point,
the British were underestimating
the intercolonial and
inter regional bonds that
were beginning to be forged
throughout the conflict thus far.
And they also were over estimating what
it would mean along those same lines to
isolate New England.
So that strategy obviously didn't end
things which leads us to the third phase
which began in 1777 and that phase
largely consisted of the British trying to
subdue the middle colonies
now states by 1777 again,
sort of the basic assumption being keep
going for those major cities and if we
get enough of those major cities,
they're going to have to cave.
So now Philadelphia and Pennsylvania
become major targets in this third phase.
And then I ended the lecture by talking
about America's shocking victory at the
battle of Saratoga, which ended up
being a real turning point in the war.
And I'm going to go a little bit more
into that reasons why that's the case
today. But I do want to mention
at the, at the very end,
after I finished my lecture on Thursday,
a few people came up to me with questions
about precisely how the Americans won
at Saratoga.
Cause I just sort of generally talked
about problems with supplies and then the
Americans won. And a few
people had questions. Well,
what actually really happened?
So I'll offer just a little bit more
detail here to give you a sense of how it
is that the Americans came to
have this unexpected victory.
So remember at that point,
British General Howe is headed off to
Philadelphia as part of the major sort of,
um,
attempt of that third phase of the war.
So General John per going is up north
with his army and Lo and behold,
part of the continental army under
her ratio gates general Horatio gates,
attacks Burgoyne and gates,
part of the army is joined by
another part of the continental army,
led by General Benjamin Lincoln.
Also militia men from nearby
areas individually and in
groups began heading to
Saratoga when they sort of got a sense
that something major was happening there.
So by October 7th of 17,
77,
there were roughly 11,000 American troops
all told facing roughly 5,000 British
troops under Burgoyne. So now we're
going isn't a little bit of trouble.
And how couldn't help him because
he's down in the south somewhere.
And for a little while for going thought
that there might be another group of
British soldiers led by Sir Henry
Clinton coming to save the day.
Clinton and his men did
not come to the rescue.
So per going is in trouble.
And to give you just a little sense
of what I'm talking about here, um,
here's a quote from a British lieutenant
who actually took part in the battle
and he writes that on October 7th
in his regiment, quote, our Canon,
we're surrounded and taken the
men and horses being all killed,
which gave them the Americans additional
spirits and they rushed on with loud
shouts when we drove them back a little
way with so great a loss to ourselves,
it evidently appeared to retreat was
the only thing left for us. Okay?
So that's a British soldier taking
part describing massive deaths.
The Americans get cheered by
what's happening and sort of surge.
And the British come to the realization
that they're going to have to retreat.
So Americans ultimately wage a war on the
actual fort at Saratoga and ultimately
breach the fort and per going withdrew
his army to the heights of Saratoga.
He lost roughly 600 men,
which was about four times the number
of Americans that are killed in that
battle.
And that's the moment where we're going
meets with his chiefs of Staff and
decides that at this point what they
need to do is actually surrender.
And I mentioned at the very
end of Thursday's lecture,
the surrender ceremony when both sides
were sort of so shocked at what was
unfolding that they,
everyone was sort of quiet and the
Americans sort of had their eyes down
supposedly because they couldn't quite
believe what was happening in front of
them.
Now I'm going to mention one last fact
regarding Saratoga that I just sort of
stumbled across today actually.
But I thought it was really interesting
because it relates back to my earlier
point about the British overestimating
the amount of loyal support that they had
in America after he lost the battle.
We're going ends up going back to England
and he ends up getting examined by
parliament to explain exactly
what happened at Saratoga.
That must've been really fun for Burgoyne.
And here are just one or two sentences
from his testimony before parliament.
He said with the Tories have risen,
why did they not rise
round Albany and below it?
At the time they found Mr.
Gates army increasing Mr. Gates,
not general gates army.
A critical insurrection from any one
point of the compass within distance to
create a diversion would probably have
secured the success of the campaign.
So there is, we're going
talking to parliament and
saying, where were the Tories?
Like just a little action.
Some diversion on the part of American
Tory's might've saved the day,
but where were they? I
didn't. They weren't there.
So he's puzzled and he's partly blaming
that for what happened at Saratoga.
So the victory at Saratoga accomplished
important things militarily.
Of course,
psychologically it was a
tremendous victory for the
Americans after a series of
somewhat less inspiring battle moments.
But in many ways,
the most important impact of the battle
of Saratoga was on the world stage
because when news of the battle reached
Europe in December of 1777 it gave some
credibility to the American cause,
particularly in France,
which the Americans had already been
eyeing as a potential source of support
during the war,
and that makes sense.
Given Francis Longstanding
and muddy to England,
it makes perfect sense that the Americans
think, hm, maybe even the French,
you're going to come eight us as we're
fighting against their longtime enemy.
Now,
Franklin,
Benjamin Franklin was in Paris at this
point when the news begins to reach
Europe,
he is serving as an American
ambassador and while he's in France,
he proved that among his many talents,
he had an amazing talent at self promotion
because although he was an extremely
cultured American,
he was incredibly shrewd at
playing the American in Paris.
Basically he knew what the French sort
of expected Americans to be like and they
thought Americans are going to be
the sort of simple, pure, virtuous,
natural backwoods been.
So there's Franklin,
he's in the splendor,
the grand splendor of the French court,
and he dressed really,
really simply.
And many of you have
probably seen this image.
He always wore this sort of for cap.
Like,
I just went out and killed myself on
animal and now I'm wearing this hat,
you know, like, yeah, I'm
a backwoods philosopher,
was basically the role he was playing
was the sort of amazing, rustic,
natural backwoods American philosopher.
He continually presented
himself in that way,
which really stood out among all
the splendor of the French court.
And the French absolutely adored it.
He became a sort of fad
of the French court.
There were countless portraits and
images made of him. He was put on dishes.
He was put on medallions,
uh, as Franklin himself,
put it in my face is now almost as
well known, is that of the moon, right?
They just adored him in France.
Apparently Franklin also knew how to
enjoy himself and France because a little
later in the war,
one of Washington's aids was sent
to France to control Franklin.
Sort of keep him from having
a little bit too much fun. Um,
let's just say that Franklin who was in
his seventies at this point, so he's,
you know,
advanced in age,
Franklin liked the ladies and the ladies
liked Franklin and particularly given
that he was the fad of the court,
I think Franklin had a very enjoyable
time in Paris. And so Washington,
one of Washington's aids actually gets
sent to sort of babies had Benjamin
Franklin.
Now all of this adulation of
Franklin irked John Adams.
Surprise,
surprise.
John Adams really sort of on some
fundamental level thought that he,
he deserves some too.
And Franklin was so beloved,
it really proved irksome to Adams.
He had kept a diary and in the diary he
tend to do record adulation moments of
Franklin.
Like here's another one of
those darn moments where
they just loved this guy. Um,
and I want to offer one just so you can
get a sense of what this would have been
like. I guess both for
Adams and Franklin. Um,
this is from Adams diary from
his journal from April 29,
1778 and this is what Adam's writes.
After dinner we went to the
Academy of Sciences Voltaire.
And Franklin were both present
and they're presently arose.
A general cry that Miss Your Voltaire,
I Miss Your Franklin should
be introduced to each other.
This was done and they bowed and spoke
to each other. This was no satisfaction.
There must be something more.
Neither of our philosophers seem to
divine what was wished or expected. They,
however, it took each other by
the hand, but this was not enough.
The clamor continued until
the explanation came out.
It'll Folsom plus Aalf ponces right?
They have to,
they have to embrace themselves.
French style,
the two aged actors upon this great
theater of philosophy and frivolity then
embraced each other by hugging
one another in their arms,
kissing each other's cheeks,
and then the tumbled subsided.
So there's Franklin sort of
everyday existence in Paris,
which was pretty extreme. So Franklin
is, they're living it up in Paris.
He's there when news of Saratoga
reaches France on hearing the News,
France decides ultimately that they're
going to formally recognize America as an
independent nation.
Obviously with Franklin and Adams
and others helping things along,
and upon recognizing America
as an independent nation,
the French went one step further and
agreed to enter the war as allies to the
Americans. So obviously Saratoga happens,
the news gets to Europe, France hears it,
and those are two major developments.
France recognizes American independence.
France joins the war on
the side of the Americans.
With this agreement, this really major
two agreements for the first time,
there seemed to be a remote possibility
that the Americans might actually have a
chance of being victorious.
This is a major,
major ally that's just signed
up on the American side.
Not only did the French bring
credibility to the American cause,
but of course they also brought military
supplies and most important of all is
we're going to see a little later in the
lecture they brought the French navy.
America at this point is still
figuring out how to have a navy.
So having the French navy
was of huge importance.
Now it's important to note at this point
that it's not the dynamic here isn't
that the French were so inspired by the
nobility of the American cause that they
decided they would join the
war with the Americans there.
That is true for some French individuals.
I'll talk a little bit more later on
in the lecture about the Marquis de
Lafayette.
He's one of a number of people
who actually were inspired
by the American cause.
But as a nation,
the French were particularly eager to
help the Americans because they assumed
that after the war they might be able
to take over much of the lucrative trade
with America that the British
had controlled before.
So basically joining America in this war
effort was an investment now that they
thought would probably pay off later.
And of course add to that the fact
that by aligning themselves with the
Americans, they're now fighting
their long term, long time enemy,
the British. So that makes it an
attractive proposition as well.
So in February of 1778 France
signed two treaties with America.
The first was the Treaty
of Amity and Commerce,
the Treaty of Amity.
And comers that said that
France recognized the
United States as a sovereign
nation.
Yeah.
It also said that France
had trading privileges with
America as a favored nation,
but America preserved the
right of free trade. Second,
France signed the Treaty of alliance
that would go into effect if war erupted
between England and France because of
the first tree,
which indeed it did five months later.
So basically the first tree of
Amity and Commerce is signed.
Britain and France now decide they're
warring and then Francis. Okay.
Now the Treaty of alliance
is going into effect.
We are now officially allied with America.
The stated purpose of the Treaty of
alliance was to assure the quote, liberty,
sovereignty and independence,
absolute and unlimited
of the United States,
France renounced claims to
the mainland of North America,
east of the Mississippi,
or to the Bermuda islands if
captured by America. In return,
France asks the United States to recognize
whatever France might capture in the
West indies.
In other words,
a France capture some British islands
in the West indies. America says, fine,
we'll recognize that for sure.
America was given a free
hand to conquer Canada.
Yay. Conquer Canada could think
we got that in the treaty.
And then,
um,
both sides agreed not to negotiate for
peace without consent of the other.
So now you've got Britain and
France in war against one another.
And with that,
the American revolution becomes something
of a world war because Spain and the
Dutch ultimately join on
the side of the French.
So now Europe and European powers and
their own disputes also ended up playing a
role in who siding with
who during the revolution.
Now it's really important to note at
this point that with the involvement of
other European nations, and particularly
with the involvement of France,
America became far less of a central
concern to the British who now felt
compelled to send thousands of soldiers
to the west to guard against French
invasion,
which means that less manpower was
available to fight in the United States,
the West indies,
or what at the time that would have been
known as the sugar islands where the
truly great prizes as far
as colonies were concerned,
they were greater prizes than
the North American colonies.
That's where the real money was in,
in the sugar islands.
So some British manpower very naturally
went right to the indies to protect
British properties from the French.
At this point,
feeling a little desperate because
of the French American alliance.
The British actually make one
last stab at reconciliation.
They're persistent though.
As we'll see in a few minutes.
They made some misjudgments
that ultimately did not
achieve the success of this
attempt.
On February 17th,
1778 lord north proposed in the House
of Commons be conciliatory propositions.
The conciliatory propositions,
February 17th, 1778
and the propositions called for the repeal
of all of the acts that Americans had
found obnoxious. Right?
Okay, well take it all back.
No standing army in time
of peace in the colonies.
No changes in colonial charters unless
colonial assemblies request them.
England would agree to consider American
representation in parliament or if
American's preferred to recognize
the American Congress as a permanent
institution. Right? Suddenly
England's like, okay,
we'll take back all the things you hate
if we just end this now based on those
propositions,
a conciliatory propositions,
a British commission was sent to America
with instructions to deal with the
continental Congress by
this point in a sense. Um,
it's also could be called
the confederation Congress,
but I'll talk more about the
confederation later on. Um,
to deal the continental congress
as if it was a legal body.
But Congress refused to appoint
commissioners to meet with a British
commissioners.
Instead,
they considered the propositions on their
own in Congress and then sent a letter
with their response to the British
commissioners as Henry Lawrence,
who's the president of the congress
at the time. Put it in this letter,
the acts of the British parliament,
the commission for your sovereign right,
your sovereign,
not our sovereign and your letter.
Suppose the people of the states to be
subjects of the crown of Great Britain
and her founded on the idea of dependence,
which is utterly inadmissible.
And Lawrence then went
on to add that, you know,
if the British wanted,
the Americans would be happy to talk
about peace if the king would either admit
American independence or withdraw
all of his forces from America.
So it's a British are ready to do that.
The Americans say we're willing
to talk to you otherwise, no,
there were not willing to admit that
we're dependent on you in any way.
This is utterly inadmissible.
Take them back.
So clearly it's too late for what
could have been some pretty radical
propositions at this point.
We come to the misjudgments because the
British commission made the fatal error
when they realize that that
angle wasn't going to work.
They tried to bribe some high
ranked American officials,
including George Washington,
who they offered to make a Duke.
If George Washington would agree to their
terms as one of the commissioners put
it, Washington is certainly to
be bought honors, we'll do it.
And I'm assuming that you
know the commission somewhere
or others thinking back
to Washington and the French and Indian
war and he's an ambitious guy and he
actually wants military honors. So the
British were thinking we can buy him,
like show them a couple honors. He's
an ambitious guy. We've got him.
They also attempted to bribe
Franklin as well. Again,
showing some misjudgment on the part of
the British towards either one of those
men.
Um,
and also assuming clearly how wonderfully
attractive British honors would be,
that they would easily seduced
either one of these two men.
Neither one of them was
attracted to this British honors.
We're not going to sway them from
their cause. So not surprisingly,
both sides of this British
effort where a complete flop.
Okay.
Now we're about to advance to the
fourth and final phase of the war.
But I do want to mention something else
that happened in the winter of 1777
before I move on to this fourth
phase. And that is the, uh,
the American armies and
camp men at valley forge.
Yeah.
They're Americans for time,
had really serious problems getting
supplies and these supplies are always a
problem generally,
partly because the congress,
the continental Congress does not
have a way of insisting on anything.
I mentioned back when we
talked about organizing a war,
the continental congress
was not very strong,
couldn't demand things from the
states, could just ask, so supplies,
organizing supplies was a problem,
but at valley forge they
became a serious problem.
Even just basic supplies like food,
partly because of the weakness of the
continental congress as well as a simple
lack of organization and
actually some graft as well.
So men were starving some of them
half naked, some froze to death,
hundreds of horses starve to death.
The army didn't dissolve or mutiny at
this point, which actually says something,
but the experience of valley
forge suggested to some
of the men at Washington's
headquarters that there were problems
with the weakness of the continental
congress.
And I'm going to come back to this lesson
in future lectures when we begin to
talk about the articles of confederation
and the lead up to the constitutional
convention because the experience of
Revolution taught some people are led,
some people to believe that
they had learned some hard
lessons about what wasn't
present there as what were during the war
as far as the government was concerned
and led them to believe something stronger
needed to be there. So in some ways,
um, working at Washington's
headquarters during the war,
it was like a little nationalist creating
machine where people at the center who
saw how things were so hard to
organize because of the weakness of the
continental congress.
Many of those people ended up believing
that there needed to be a stronger
government after the war that will
come in future lectures. Okay.
That brings us to the fourth
and final phase of the war.
It's the southern campaign.
The southern campaign
lasted from 1779 to 1781
and this phase is marked by a decision
on the part of the British to transfer
their attention to the south,
hoping that by possessing ports of
the south closer to the West indies,
they can maybe maneuver there fighting
better. They can keep their eye on,
was ever have whatever's
happening in the indies.
They can also fight the
Americans in the south as well.
Here the British again made a faulty
assumption because they assumed that the
south would be an easy target because
they assumed that there'd be a large
reservoir of loyalist support,
so they really assumed they
would seize key southern ports.
There'd be all these loyalists there to
help them and then they would move their
way back north,
taking one region after another
as they worked their way north.
So the British sailed to the Carolinas.
They took Charles town, South Carolina,
which was the most important
city south of Philadelphia.
They then left behind British general
Charles Co Cornwallis with kind of a
mopping up crew in the south while the
rest of the army began to move north to
attack the rest of the continental army.
Between 1779 and 1781,
there was a series of battles between the
Americans and the British in the south.
American suffered defeat after defeat.
They persisted,
but they were not winning these
battles. The British one, Georgia,
they already had Charleston and then the
British began to pursue the Americans
into Virginia and that's where
the Americans began to rally.
Now, in part, this is due
once again to supply problems.
This time for the British
army, um, for Cornwallis,
the British supply lines were stretched
to their maximum and continued fighting
was beginning to take a real toll on
Cornwallis his forces who suffered worse
losses than were expected,
particularly considering they hadn't
really expected much in the way of losses
at all.
Also,
loyalists remained largely
silent in the south,
partly because the British didn't
really treat them very well.
The British didn't do anything
to court loyalists and the south.
The British ruled captured areas in
the south under martial law and made no
allowances for loyalists.
They didn't grant any power to loyalists.
So basically they did nothing
to solicit loyalist support,
and thus they didn't get
much loyalists support.
So Cornwallis is following
the American army.
He limps into Virginia
with a supply problem.
And while the British army is in Virginia,
they plundered George
Washington's plantation.
Mount Vernon just for like a little zing,
you know. Well, as long as we're here,
let's attack Mount Vernon.
Um,
they took slaves as they left George
Washington's plantation manager,
Lund Washington,
to protect the plantation to
prevent further damage being done.
Actually went on board a British vessel
in a nearby harbor and served the
British RefreshMints right.
So please don't attack Mount Vernon
and maybe you'll even give us back our
slaves. And I'm bringing
food. Have some cookies.
I don't know what they brought,
but they forgot. Refreshmints um,
this did not please George Washington
at all as he wrote to Lund Washington to
go on board their vessels,
carry them refreshments.
Commune with a parcel of
plundering scoundrels and
request a favor by asking the
surrender of my negroes
was exceedingly ill judged.
It would have been a less painful
circumstance to me to have heard that in
consequence of your non
compliance with their requests.
They had burnt my house and
laid the plantation in ruins.
Not really good judgment on
the part of London, Washington.
Can you imagine like he,
he's sort of on their,
on the boat sort of hanging out with the
British and he's clearly a relation of
the guy leading the continental
army. It's like not good, not good,
not good thinking on the part of London,
Washington,
but so Cornwallis is in Virginia.
He forms a new base of action
after he's plundered Mount Vernon.
He forms the new base
of action at Yorktown,
Virginia near the coast,
planning to fan out into
Pennsylvania and Virginia.
But just then August 30 1781 a French
fleet under French Admiral de Grasse
arrived at the Virginia coast with troops.
And as we're about to see,
this ends up being a really crucial
turning point for what's happening in
Virginia. And then ultimately
for the war as a whole,
Washington had troops on land in Virginia,
but in the end it was the arrival of the
French fleet in the harbor that really
decided the battle because basically it's
surrounded the British and they had no
way to escape the troops,
surrounded them on land.
They probably would have tried to
escape to their ships in the harbor,
but now the French fleet was
there making that impossible.
If the French fleet had arrived at
the wrong time or in the wrong place,
this plan would have collapsed
and sort of miraculously,
they actually get to the right place at
the right time for the plan to really go
into effect.
So the arrival of the French really looks
bad for the British and Cornwallis is
low on supplies.
He's also low on men at this point,
and now he's trapped at Yorktown,
trapped between American
forces and the French fleet,
which now put the British under siege.
So Corn Wallace is roughly 7,000 men
and there actually were some loyalists
fighting there, so they didn't antagonize
all the loyalists in the south.
There was some fighting alongside
the British at Yorktown.
Cornwallis is roughly 7,000 men held
off a siege of roughly 15,000 combined
American and French
troops for three weeks,
which is actually a pretty
amazing accomplishment,
but ultimately Cornwallis
was forced to surrender.
On October 17th,
Cornwallis wrote a terse
note to Sir Henry Clinton,
who was then in command of the British
forces in America. He wrote, quote,
I have the mortification to inform Your
Excellency that I had been forced to
surrender the troops under my command
by capitulation on the 19th incident as
prisoners of war to the combined
forces of America and France. Period.
Mortified is a good word.
He could not believe what had happened
stunned by what happened in this battle
and just the incredible drama of the
moment. There are actually many, many,
many eyewitness accounts of what was
unfolding at Yorktown because people
understood on all sides that
something major was happening.
People described during
the formal surrender and
October 19th the slow passage
of the British troops past the eyes of
the American troops who are lined up in
two columns that
stretched for half a mile.
The British band played a tune
titled the world turned upside down,
which they surely felt it was.
Witnesses said that the British
looked quote unsold Shirley.
And I think what that means is
according to another witness,
they were very much in liquor.
So I'm British, I'm mortified.
Not just the Cornwallis, but they're
mortified. And basically they were drunk.
They couldn't quite believe
that this was happening.
Someone said that their ranks for
broken in their step was irregular.
Cornwallis was so mortified
that he claimed to be sick
and refuse to attend the
surrender.
And he sent a deputy to surrender his
sword to Washington and Washington who's
so good at sort of upholding
the dignity of the cause,
refuse to accept the sword from a deputy
and had it delivered to his deputy.
So that terms were equal.
Washington's always good at this sort
of symbolic gesture and Wa and then the
British, as they were marching
by the American troops,
they had to lay down their arms
under the terms of the surrender.
And when the British were
told to lay down their arms,
one witness noted that quote there,
mortification could not be concealed.
I am a witness that they performed this
duty in a very anonymous or like manner
and that many of the soldiers manifested
a sullen temper throwing their arms on
the pile with violence as if
determined to render them useless.
We're not to be surprised at the pride
or the British officers is humbled on
this occasion as they
have always entertained an
exalted opinion of their own
military prowess and affected to
view the Americans as a contemptible
undisciplined rabble.
Now here we come to some documents I
want to mention just cause I discovered
them years ago at the library of Congress
and I found them so interesting at the
time. Um, it's just something I
would never had thought of before,
which is the glory of doing research
when you're a historian is you just never
know what you're gonna find.
Um, and I was actually,
I was at the library of Congress.
Um, I was actually researching,
um, dueling, right? So what,
what I really wanted to know was
supposedly Americans learned to duel by
watching the French during the revolution
and they think this is such a great
idea. They take it themselves.
Sounds dubious to me.
But I was researching this to see
if I could find any record of this.
And I found these letters from between
actually British commanders and French
commanders during the
surrender at Yorktown.
And what was fascinating about them
is that the British and the French are
writing to each other.
And what they're both basically saying
in their letters is that the British are
saying, okay, would you please tell
the Americans to step out of the way?
Because they don't know
how to do a surrender.
They don't know what they're doing.
And they're in the way like,
just please French commander
tell the Americans to step aside.
Because they're pesky and they're amateurs
and the French are basically writing
back to the British and saying, yeah, we
understand the Americans are in the way.
You know, aren't they cute?
Those little Americans,
well we'll have the step off
to the side like you and I,
we know how to really have a
real surrender. Don't worry.
Like your knees will be tended to.
So basically I found these letters in
which the French and the English were
treating each other as absolute equals
and neither one was treating the
Americans as equals on the same plane.
And it really gives you a sense of
how the French and the English were.
These sort of long time old world war
veterans who even though they were enemies
really sort of understood
and appreciated each other.
And the Americans are such little
sort of pipsqueak newcomers,
they're not even on the radar screen.
So I thought that was fascinating
to find the French and the English,
not what I thought I would
find. I was like, oh cool.
Letters between the French and the British
during Yorktown. Hey, wait a minute.
The French are telling us to get out
of the way. So it was interesting.
It really gives you a sense of of sort
of American status, relatively speaking,
back in England,
one witness was with Lord north when he
received word of the loss at Yorktown
and is this witness wrote north,
took the news as he would have taken a
shot in the breast for he opened his arms
exclaiming wildly as he
paced up and down Oh God.
It is all over words,
which he repeated many times under
emotions of the deepest consternation and
distress. So at this point, England,
which has already overtaxed,
definitely sees no sign
of victory on the horizon,
decide to commence peace negotiations.
Now clearly you can see
how French aid had a major,
major impact on what happened at Yorktown.
And that's on the war in general.
The French gave supplies, they
gave men, they gave naval support,
they gave moral support, they
distracted the British in lots of ways.
The French had a huge influence
on the outcome of the war. Now,
I noted earlier that French self-interest
played some role in the decision of
the French to join on the
side of the Americans,
but it is also worth noting that there
were some Frenchman who came to the aid
of America because they actually really
did get swept up into the American
revolutionary cause and they saw it as
a justified fight for freedom in the
marquis. De Lafayette is maybe
the most notable example of this.
He was really young at the time. He
was about 19 years old. He's a marquee,
so he's clearly very wealthy.
Um,
and obviously he was really moved
by what was going on in America.
So he actually took a large ship,
loaded it with men and supplies and
sailed to America just to volunteer his
ship, his men, his supplies, and himself.
Here I am joining the American cause and
he ended up being this really beloved
figure in America.
I mean,
Washington really almost treated him
like a son when you read letters, uh,
that Washington rights and why, why she's
not exactly a cozy kind of individual.
Um, but clearly he had a lot
of affection for Lafayette.
But Americans in general really admired
and appreciated Lafayette because he was
sort of this starry eyed youth who
sacrificed for the American cause for no
reason. He just appeared because
he was swept into the cause.
And between 1824 and 1825 right on the
cusp of the 50th anniversary of the
declaration of independence,
Lafite had actually came back to America
for the sort of triumphal tour you have
to sort of visit old friends that he
met with like Jefferson and Adams.
And I think Andrew Jackson like,
you know,
by 1824 there's a weird conglomeration
of people that he's meeting with. Um,
but he went on a grand
tour of all of America.
He went to all of the 24 states and he
think he was in his seventies at the time.
So He's, he's pretty vigorous.
Um, and he was celebrated.
He was paraded all over the place. He
had receptions where he sort of hung out,
like ready to talk to Americans.
Americans of all kinds would line
up on the street just to see him,
to watch parades go by to look at him,
enter their city.
So he was beloved at the time.
Then was sort of in a way maybe he
sort of symbolized French assistance,
the French alliance afterwards
cause America Americans
gave a lot of love to the
Marquis de Lafayette.
And it's important to note,
I mean I'm mentioning Lafayette cause
he's maybe the best known figure,
but he's not the only freshmen who
volunteered to come and fight for the
American cause.
And actually France is not the only
country where people came voluntarily to
join the American cause.
So back to the French,
the aid of the French clearly major,
major factor in the American victory.
And with the American victory at
Yorktown in 1781 the British decided to
commence peace negotiations.
It is important to note that even though
the British have now informally decided
that they're going to start
negotiating for peace,
it doesn't mean that there was
an instant cease fire in the war.
There was kind of a fuzzy period here in
which there was still a sizable British
armed force in America.
The British hadn't officially
declared surrender.
Authorities in London told British forces
that they should avoid battle unless
attacked and they should
begin to evacuate troops.
But Yorktown was not really
like the instant end of the
revolution and there are
still skirmishes and battles afterwards.
For some time,
people don't have any way of
really knowing the war is over.
There's still a British army there.
It's not until June of 1782 that
negotiations began in Paris.
American sent a commission of Foreman,
John Adams, Benjamin Franklin, John Jay,
and Henry Laurens.
Um,
it's interesting to note that even now,
okay,
Yorktown surrender war over,
we're going to have a peace negotiation.
Even now,
the British still hope that maybe there'd
be some way to come to terms with the
Americans that would still somehow
leave America within the British empire.
They're really persistent.
And it wasn't until John Jay arrived in
Paris and he's a no nonsense sort of,
you know, straight forward
person. Jay Actually said, look,
we're not going to proceed with peace
negotiations unless independence is
assumed. Guys. Like, okay,
and this is not negotiable.
We're independent. We're over.
It wasn't until he really insisted that
negotiations began and independence was
really finally accepted as
inevitable by the British.
So Britain recognized
American independence.
They agreed to evacuate all
royal troops from American soil.
John Adams thinking of New England got
American fishing rights off of the grand
banks of Canada.
Canada appears again.
I'd like the fact that John Adams is there
working for fishing rights. Look, yeah.
Yeah. Independence. Fishing
rights. Thank you. John Adams. Um,
the American's promised that they would
urge state legislatures to compensate
loyalists for property loss during the
war and agreed that British creditors be
able to collect prewar debts.
Even though those two very nice things
were agreed to by the Americans. In fact,
neither one happened in a very reliable
manner and created all sorts of problems
because there are a lot of states that
were just not really excited about
compensating loyalists or
about repaying the British.
No mention was made of native Americans,
many of whom had supported the
British for really logical reasons,
given their fears about the spreading
domination of an independent American
republic with settlers swallowing up land.
And ultimately many Indian nation simply
didn't recognize American claims of
sovereignty over their
territory for the Americans.
Overall independence had been won,
but at a high price and actually only
the civil war produced a higher ratio of
casualties to the nation's population.
And still undecided at the close
of the war were too obvious.
Big major questions.
What kind of society was America going
to become and what kind of government
with the new nation and it states possess.
These are two questions which are going
to be talking about in lectures to come
on Thursday,
I'm going to talk about American society.
And then we sort of segue
into a discussion of people
wondering exactly what's
supposed to be happening,
what kind of a national
something is supposed to be
governing over these states.
Um,
and that's gonna lead us up to why a
constitutional convention actually made
sense because it didn't
make sense to everybody.
And it took a while for it
to make sense to anybody.
So that's to come.
Uh,
I will conclude there and
I will see you on Thursday.